pay attention to any of the uh
i guess the chatter from national
talking heads about maybe criticizing
the move to start you at all yeah no
no um
yeah not not to be not to be rude or
disrespectful in any way uh
i don't i don't pay attention to any of
that stuff um
i care about the opinions of those
closest to me my friends my family
my teammates my coaches
and uh you know you get to this level
and
you kind of you have to have tunnel
vision and
do your thing you and drew are tight uh
what was he like for you this week uh
going into this first start
man drew's the best um
you know if if i'm being honest i i
didn't fully
understand what it took to be a starter
in the nfl um
until i got here and i had the
opportunity to learn from zoom
andrew is with me every step of the way
this week as we watched film
he was constantly asking me
uh what i needed
and how he could be helpful
and so he was
and he was so critical he was
such a comfort you know for me to have
around and uh
you know
i look up to him so much he's become one
of my best friends
[Music]
jason hill in his first start had 23
passes prior to that including
postseason he had 20 career throws he
more than doubled his career passing
attempts in one afternoon and he had a
couple of touchdowns rushing he had four
rushing touchdowns in his entire career
coming into the game uh look it it was a
little sputtery yeah at first that's
right it was choppy
there was the throw that reminded me of
the old sand lot kickoff you know when
you play sandlot football you don't
actually kick off you just throw the
ball high and deep right that's what it
looked like it worked it was caught and
then it looked like it was fumbled but
down by contact was the ruling accurate
ruling but you know taysom hill was
efficient 18 for 23. he was taysom hill
when it was time to run the ball scores
a touchdown on fourth and goal and and i
think so far and i asked him after the
game talked to him for a good six seven
minutes what grade would you give
yourself and he him then hot and i need
to look at the film and then he kept
going if you just let him keep going
they'll eventually come to the point
where he wanted to be
b or a b plus is the grade that he gave
himself for the game what grade would
you give him i i think that's fair i
think that it really is i mean if you're
going to be realistic about the
situation right mike and this is a guy
that
i mean he hasn't played quarterback he
just he was you know very respectful and
open and honest with just that little
clip he showed right there
you know just realizing whoa i just
didn't realize when you're the starter
of what it takes to prepare the whole
week and be the guy
and everybody's always looking to you
and asking questions and hey what about
this blade hey you got this and got that
i'm sure that was exhausting let alone i
heard sean payton in the post game press
conference yeah you know early in the
early on he was a little nervous he said
some plays wrong we flipped the
formation
i i've been there it's exactly i mean it
doesn't matter how many times you
practice that all of a sudden you get in
the intensity of the game and it's your
first you know start and you're looking
at the other team and you're thinking
about what you've got to do and you're
getting a huddle and even though you've
you've set a play 50 times during the
week you can't spit it out the right way
when you need to and all of a sudden you
do stupid stuff like that it was very
choppy like you said early on but
the defense played awesome
he really only made one bad mistake that
ended up being a dropped interception
down there in the red area and they
slowly but surely found the formula in
which how they wanted to play and how to
use him and i think overall he really
managed the game the right way he made
the run game more effective and he made
some nice plays on his own let alone
some nice plays and rhythm within the
offense too
when i talked to him it was clear it
bothered him that he fumbled the ball
late they were up 24-9 but when you are
suffocating a team and they and they
have a dangerous offense if they can
ever wake it up into the credit of the
saints defense yeah they weren't able to
wake it up with the falcons offense on
sunday but that really bothered him
that's why he downgraded himself to a b
or a b plus and the other thing he needs
to do and he explained this to me he
just wants more tempo he wants that
saints offense in and out of the huddle
calling the plays getting the play calls
right moving things quickly because the
tempo is what can keep the defense on
its heels and they're even more on their
heels when you don't know what taysom
hill is going to do with it because the
one thing drew brees never was going to
be ever
was a threat to run the ball now you've
got this guy who can do either thing you
have to be ready for either thing you
never know what he's going to do and
he's not going to get worse
with more reps he's only going to get
better with more reps the challenge
comes and we may not see enough games
this year to get to the point where
defenses can devise
a better way to try to stop him but you
know defenses have seen this guy it's
not like he's some new thing he's been
around for a few years they've been
using him periodically defenses at least
have have had a crack at trying to
figure out what to do when taysom hill's
on the field and he has the ball in his
hands and i think that that challenge is
only going to become more and more
significant it was funny last week
because remember we were saying and we
kept showing the graphic of the depth
chart like what like everything's point
to taste early in the week you called
this baby
like i'm and then everyone's like no
it's going to be james winston's shut up
you don't know what you're talking about
it's going to be jameis winston i'm like
well maybe it is going to be jameis
winston and then by the end of the week
it becomes taysom hill and hill told me
he he had a pretty good idea monday
night it was going to be him i said are
you surprised that
that you guys kept it under wraps for so
long he said no not with sean payton
around and that's what he did he managed
to get those guys to zip it tight all
week long
and uh and then he trolled i love it
roddy white roddy white tweeted this
on
saturday saints about to whip us trying
with taysom hill quarterback we about to
snack them that was immediately
retweeted by sean payton probably from
the locker room while they were dancing
after the victory over the atlanta
falcons hopefully with their matters on
this time but but but peyton's a genius
he is peyton's a genius that's right
peyton's a genius yes because let me
tell you even on friday after it came
out that hill was going to be the
starter there was still a sense he was
going to use both guys and for all we
know he was ready to put jameis winston
in if he needed to he just ultimately
didn't need to and taysom hill proved it
and you know the report yesterday and
this makes sense i agree with it ian
rappaport said that one of the big
factors was sean payton wants to see
what taysom hill can do as a quarterback
and we all do and i guess he had some
nerves early in the week and i think
that act of making it a build up of
making it a bigger deal like you take a
regular season game and you give it a
playoff feel and the wisdom of that is
simple this guy may be playing in
playoff games yeah let's go ahead and
throw him into it let's make it as big
of a game otherwise saints falcons week
11 who the hell cares let's make it into
a big game let's see how he does when
the stakes are high because that's going
to prepare him if we do need him down
the stretch in a big game or next year
if he's the starter and the big games
come around and the playoffs game that's
just it's another level of the genius of
sean payton definitely turn this into
something bigger than it was just to
help take some hill better prepare
himself for the future yeah no i think i
mean it helps everybody in the
organization prepare for the future i
mean you know to what you're saying i i
did you know i wasn't sure i thought
they'd start jamis he'd just be scared
to play taysom hill who hasn't played
you know quarterback in the nfl but
obviously he had seen enough to know
okay i think he's ready enough
and yeah let's see what he's got i mean
we've heard all you know the rumors
about sean payton gushing about taysom
hill and everything like that and i
think where it's really cool too you
know you said it you know one the team
is good right there's a lot of positive
things sean payton's a genius he's
definitely one of the greatest offensive
minds in the history of the sport that's
what he'll go down as and
here again you see the versatility you
know really the one thing that jumped
out to me that where they started to
settle in that i noticed and and really
producer matt casey was the one that
pointed it out as we were going along
they got into basically every time he
dropped back was a little token play
action pass hey let's protect the line
let's protect let's let him get some
depth off a play-action pass so we can
separate between him and the offensive
line
that gives him the ability to run if he
has to but now we've run play action
pass we've sucked the linebackers up and
that's where we saw michael thomas get
involved in the game to where we haven't
really seen that involvement from him
all year where yeah you know taysom hill
he he's a little more aggressive wanting
to push the ball down the field and do
those things and plus because of his
running ability
you get defenses that more are oh we
have to worry about stopping the run and
therefore the 15 and 20 yard completions
right behind the linebackers at that
second level and all those things
start to become more open and more
effective and that's where we really saw
i think the change in the game i mean
you see they have three rushers for
right around 50 yards
he took care of the football michael
thomas got 100 yards
receiving and when he didn't like what
he saw out of those play-action passes
he took off and ran and damn that's a
good combo when you got you know that
type of offense and that defense who we
haven't even talked about who whoop some
butt yesterday uh they can play with
anybody with that type of formula
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports